une ambition et une ampleur historique
100 milliards c'est près de quatre fois
plus que le plan de relance qui avaient
été mises en oeuvre pour faire face à la
crise de 2008 7 en proportion de la
richesse nationale
le plan de relance le plus massifs
annoncés à ce jour parmi les grands pays
européens 100 milliards c'est surtout le
montant dont notre économie a besoin
c'est le montant nécessaire pour
retrouver dès 2022
notre niveau de richesse d'avant la
crise c'est un objectif ambitieux mais
parfaitement à notre portée pour cela
trois leviers structurants d'abord
atténuée au maximum pour les entreprises
et des salariés
dans le prolongement des mesures déjà
prises les effets de la récession
économique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rôle
contracyclique du plan repartir relancer
l'activité
deuxième levier deuxième objectif
combattre et réduire les morsures de la
crise sur notre pacte social et
territorial en engageant des moyens pour
celles et ceux de nos concitoyens et de
nos territoires les plus menacés les
jeunes les précaires les personnes en
situation de handicap
les bassins d'emploi les plus touchés
troisième objectif essentiel accélérer
la transformation de notre économie en
tirant les enseignements structurelles
de la crise et en confortant la logique
réformatrice du quinquennat ce sont les
investissements massifs en faveur de la
transition écologique et de la
souveraineté et de la compétitivité
économique de la france qui doivent
permettre
de nous positionner sur les créneaux les
plus porteurs dans les dix prochaines
années et